c'était dédié en direct du 10/10 foule
m
rio
et non le meilleur jeu
d'accord
j
et voilà c'est déjà fort de ce petit
montage de la paris games week 2012
j'espère boucane qui vous aura plu
oui je ne vais pas sortir même temps que
tous les autres tubes heures parce que
je trouvais ça un peu con qu'il va
appeler parisienne suc d'un coup et au
moins là ça fait genre d'appli quelques
bons souvenirs et puis vint quelques
découvertes pour ceux qui n'étaient pas
là
en tout cas vous pouvez vous rattraper
l'année prochaine parce que bat chaque
année alors la paris games week et c'est
de plus en plus condensé de plus en plus
de gens et tout est pour ceux qui n'ont
pas vu ma vidéo sur la japan expo 2012
donc ça c'était au mois de juillet je
leur pelouse a été bloqué sur ma chaîne
pour des droits d'auteur mais je les
repos dont vous pouvez la voir en
cliquant dessus juste là c'est aussi un
montage et reine du genre un peu plus
long avec un beaucoup plus de fun et
puis va aussi falloir les pylônes des
vacances c'est par ici
si vous aimez les petits montages irène
n'hésitez pas à me le dire et on se
retrouve bientôt dans de prochaines
vidéos notamment - maman maman what the
fuck the boys notamment avec mon frère
sur mario sur wii où ça risque d'être
épique sous forme de best-of tu as tout
le monde puisse bientôt
à
m